deuxième match d'improvisation pour les
jeunes de déclic théâtre toujours à la
manière d'un tournoi de hockey sur glace
les cadets de la compagnie divisés en
deux équipes se sont affrontées durant
plus d'une heure sur deux thématiques
décaler le public enjoué à encourager
son équipe favorite par un système de
vote et n'a pas hésité à huer certaines
décisions de larbitre un arbitre joué
par la coach des cadets qui s'est déjà
sur quoi accès les prochains ateliers du
mercredi pour emmener ses jeunes de 12 à
15 ans encore plus loin là il ya
certains qu'on a pu voir au cours du
match
décrocher ce qu'on appelle le décrochage
c'est quand il rit à leurs propres
blagues
donc ça il ya un travail encore sur la
barrière entre personnes et personnages
dont on va continuer là-dessus et après
essayer d'aller plus vers des émotions
réaliste vers le staff fier de
l'évolution de ces étoiles montantes
dresse un bilan prometteur
on voit que les élèves ont les joueurs
pour essayer que et qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya des connexions
des rapports en tout cas amicaux qui
sont créées qui font qu'il arrive à
répondre plus facilement du tac au tac
et tout ça ils prennent aussi conscience
des uns et des autres des forces des uns
et des autres est effectivement voilà il
ya il ya beaucoup de choses positives
dans ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui à
mi-parcours
cette année la saison 2013 se clôturera
avec le tournoi intergénérationnel qui
mélange comédiens amateurs et
professionnels de déclic théâtre la
compagnie fête d'ailleurs ses 20 ans
cette année